je pensais c'était
tout au téléphone la mère du défunt
joueur de hockey vedette Guy Lafleur
n'en croyait pas ses oreilles
lorsqu'elle a reçu un appel du cabinet
du premier ministre du Québec car j'ai
répondu je suis le secrétaire de
monsieur Legault
si tu veux hier j'ai pas réalisé
aujourd'hui ça m'énerve
je comptais pour lui je compte ça pour
la famille de la fleur la prend souvent
le taureau 50 pour aller à Montréal la
mère du joueur étoile est émue de
constater que Guy la fleur est toujours
aussi vivant dans le cœur de la
communauté de teursault sa ville natale
d'avoir l'autoroute villa Flor ça sent
toute heureux parce que je n'attendais
pas
pour lui parce qu'il lui hérite de
travailler fort des résidents de
turseaux se réjouissent eux aussi de
l'annonce le fait que l'autoroute
s'appelle Guy Lafleur
je pense que c'est une belle
reconnaissance il mérite ça c'est lui
qui a fait connaître la religion c'est
quand même une légende
et c'est bien que son nom reste
pour toujours la nouvelle devrait être
officiellement annoncée par Québec le 4
mai prochain lors d'une cérémonie
d'inauguration à sursaut selon les
politiques de toponymie du Québec il
faut attendre au moins un an après le
décès d'une personne pour utiliser son
nom à des fins de désignation comme
hémorative l'annonce survient donc plus
d'une année après que le démon blanc est
succombé à un cancer du poumon à l'âge
de 70 ans le 22 avril 2022 ici Camille
cassis Simonet Radio-Canada sursaut